well the las vegas community is a giving
and caring community
it certainly is so many of our viewers
are doing great things all around the
valley
we've launched a segment to tell their
stories called eight points of community
pride
we're recognizing tonight the children's
heart foundation helping families of
young people in our community living
with heart problems
tomorrow you can help in its mission it
is the 18th annual walk with the heart
of a child
these fundraisers are the backbone of
what they do
we're coming out of a really stressful
year
our state shut down the same week that
we were
that we had our scheduled walk last year
so
this walk this year is very meaningful
not only to the families that we serve
but it's bringing our community together
everyone is invited to them out to craig
ranch park for the fun again it's
tomorrow
at craig ranch park in north las vegas
check-in starts at nine in the morning
the one-mile fun one fun walk that is
kicks off at 9 45.
you can register and get more
information at chfn.org
and our own sherry swentz will be out
there to make sure and say hi
also if you have a story of our
community coming together please do
share it with us go to our website at
8newsnow.com
and we know